>> Trey: WELCOME BACK TO THIS
SPECIAL EDITION OF "HANNITY,"
TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP TRAVELED
TO NEW YORK CITY TO VISIT HIS
BROTHER ROBERT WHO WAS
HOSPITALIZED WITH A SERIOUS
ILLNESS.
FOX NEWS IS ALEX HOGAN IS LIVE
WITH THE LATEST ON THIS.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS IN
NEW JERSEY BUT EARLIER TODAY HE
STOPPED HERE ON THE UPPER EAST
SIDE OF MANHATTAN WHERE HIS
BROTHER ROBERT WAS HOSPITALIZED,
THE PRESIDENT MAKING THAT STOP
FOR ABOUT AN HOUR, THE
WHITE HOUSE NOT ELABORATING ON
HIS CONDITION BUT SAYING THAT HE
IS SERIOUSLY ILL.
ROBERT IS THE YOUNGEST OF FIVE
SIBLINGS COME AT A PRESS
BRIEFING, THE PRESIDENT
COMMENTING ON THEIR BROTHERLY
BOND.
>> I HAVE A WONDERFUL BROTHER,
WE HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP FOR
A LONG TIME, FROM DAY ONE.
IT’S A LONG TIME AGO AND HE’S IN
THE HOSPITAL RIGHT NOW.
HOPEFULLY HE WILL BE ALL RIGHT.
HE’S HAVING A HARD TIME.
SPEAK OF THE 72-YEAR-OLD SERVED
AS A FORMER TOP EXECUTIVE WITHIN
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION, HE
MARRIED HIS LONGTIME PARTNER IN
MARCH AND TWO MONTHS AGO,
ROBERTS TRUMP FILED TEMPORARY
RESTRAINING ORDER TRYING TO
BLOCK A TELL-ALL BOOK BY HIS
NIECE MARY.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, ROBERT WAS
HOSPITALIZED FOR ABOUT A WEEK,